it so um
it's a real pleasure to have uh lenny
suskin here from from stanford
uh lenny is um is one of the deepest
thinkers in quantum gravity he's
he's
he's one of the fathers of string theory
my my colleague raphael busso uh
puts it this way he says
lenny put the string in string theory
um
so he uh
i you know i i won't say too much here
but uh but let me just say that um
um
you know that uh
lenny has this irresistible clarity with
which he presents his uh his work and
you know maybe this is this is one of
the one of the
uh one of the qualities that that's led
him to you know he's he's actually
um one of the people who has steered the
field and so uh
you know i'm i'm really looking forward
to hearing what lenny has to say about
about quantum gravity and the
and the uh
you know quantum extended gesturing
thesis so
looking forward to it
to you
so
now i can share my screen
yes
all right let's try that
you won't be able to see me i think my
my setup doesn't allow that but i don't
think you'll be losing too much that way
start broadcast
can you see that
yes
all right let me start
my computer a little bit
i see you on the corner do you see me
i i can see you yeah
can yes
oh okay so somehow i didn't think you
could
um i think you're gonna wind up seeing
the ceiling mostly
okay
i
uh those of you who know me know of
course that i am
first of all 82 years old second of all
i am not a complexity theorist
uh
i was
pretty much about 73 years old before i
even began to start to think about it
and
at my age you don't learn things easily
and quickly
so that's just by way of disclaimer it's
also
a
true fact
so i'm going to be talking about things
which quite honestly i know very little
about
complexity theory
but in particular
i'll talk about the
during the church touring thesis the
various versions of the church touring
thesis
the church touring theses what are they
are they computer science are they
physics are they mathematics are they
philosophy
i suppose in some sense they're all of
them
but whatever it is
they are what they are and they form a
kind of interesting um
set of guidelines for thinking about the
connection
between information between computer
science
and physics
and i think there's a great deal of
value in
exploring the connections
even if
the precise version
of these theses is not not
completely well known and i think it's
not completely well known but uh let's
begin let's let me just outline what are
the various theses that we're talking
about
probably most of you know this better
than i do
uh there's the original church touring
thesis
anything that can be computed by nature
can be computed by a turing machine i'm
not at all sure this is the way either
of those people said it
but that's what it comes down to
anything that can be computed by a
natural process can be computed by a
turing machine
this idea is closely connected to
wigner's
puzzling question what is it that makes
mathematics so effective in studying the
laws of nature
the answer is of course the laws of
nature are mathematical
well if mathematics is by definition
computation not all mathematicians will
agree that it is computation but at
least some mathematicians would consider
mathematics to be basically computation
and the laws of physics are
mathematically mathematical then it
pretty much follows
that um
that anything that can be computed by
nature
can be computed by a touring machine
so
is it true i think it's true
is it interesting i think it's
interesting is it a tautology maybe but
it's one of these interesting
tautologies
next we come to the extended church
touring thesis
anything that becomes that can be
computed efficiently efficiently i take
the mean in less than exponential time
or less than exponential number of steps
anything or perhaps a polynomial number
of steps anything that can be computed
efficiently by nature can be computed
efficiently by a turing machine
now this is a very interesting example
because it's known to be false or at
least believed to be false
uh
there's nothing like having something
which turns out to be false
to convince yourself that had some
uh that it that it actually had some
meaning
and that it can be refuted
why is it false it's false because we
think that quantum computers
can compute things that could not be or
that quantum mechanics because of
quantum mechanics
uh
nature can compute things efficiently
the turing machine could not a classical
touring machine
that led to what is called the quantum
extended
church touring thesis
and that was a simple elevation of the
idea from classical physics to quantum
mechanics and it said that anything that
can be computed efficiently by nature
can be computed efficiently by a quantum
computer
now is this true
most i think people would say yes most
people most people never heard of it but
most probably people in the audience
here would say yes it's true
probably true
i have one question about it it's not so
obvious to me
that quantum field theory
because of all of its infinities and
because of it all of its subtleties
cannot in principle compute things which
could not be computed
on a by a quantum computer by a
conventional quantum computer
uh it comes down to the question of
whether a quantum field theory can be
simulated by qubits
if a quantum field theory really cannot
be can be simulated by qubits then you
might wonder whether the quantum field
theory can do things that a system of
qubits can't but i'm going to leave that
out now i'm not going to get into that
uh although i think it is an interesting
question
can an arbitrary quantum field theory be
simulated
quantum simulated by a system of qubits
okay but we're now undergoing a paradigm
shift
in fact i would say that we can judge
the revolutionary character or paradigm
shift in physics
by how much it makes us
rethink
the church touring theses and we are
undergoing a paradigm shift in physics
now
the quantum gravity shift it's full of
surprising ideas
like that the horizon area is equal to
entropy the holographic principle
something called er equals epr which
i'll mention a little bit later
volume equals complexity spatial volume
equals complexity all sorts of
surprising ideas
and in my view it would be quite
surprising if this paradigm shift did
not make us rethink to some extent
the quantum extended church during
thesis
uh can you excuse me for a moment while
i shut my door getting a little bit of
noise in here and i want to uh i want to
shut my
door to keep the noise from coming in
hold on be right back in a second
okay
all right the context of my discussion
now is going to be very conventional
from the point of view of computation
and so forth
we're going to be thinking about qubits
universal circuits
k local gates gates which are composed
out of a small number of
qubits at a time k of them at a time
where k is much smaller than the size of
the computer
we will think about uh fast scrambling
or at least i will use some of the
concepts of fresh scrambling what is
fast scrambling
fast scrambling is just uh the process
by which
if you were to add a qubit
to a
ongoing computation in a computer
if the computation was governed by uh by
universal laws and if it was in
particular if the quantum computer was
behaving chaotically
it's just a question of how long it
would take for that qubit to be
thoroughly absorbed
information theoretically into the guts
of the quantum computer
uh how long it would take for it become
very difficult to extract back out
the scrambling time is called t star
it's typically avoid a logarithm of the
number of qubits
i won't be using that very much but i
just want to mention it
uh complexity evolution is an important
idea in what i'll be talking about
i'm not going to talk about it at great
length you can find um discussions of it
in various places that i've written in
particular my princeton lectures a
couple of years ago
on connection between black holes and
complexity
complexity evolution means if you start
with a simple state
uncomplex
oh by complexity of course i mean
circuit complexity
circuit complexity is how many steps how
many how many geets does it take
in order to what's the minimum number of
gates that it takes in order to
accomplish whatever it is you're trying
to accomplish
uh
complexity evolution means that if you
start with a simple state it will simply
get more complex
that's more or less obvious up to some
point
and
the ideas of circuit complexity that i
have drawn on
are first of all just basic circuit
complexity
nielsen's geometric ideas
uh of converting questions of complexity
into differential geometry
a version of nielsen's idea which is due
to brown and myself
but i don't think we need to get into
that too much the main important thing
is there is a concept of complexity and
it is fairly universal
or that's an assumption that it's fairly
universal all these different ways of
thinking about complexity
as long as the complexity is not too
small will pretty much give you the same
complexity
if that were not true then complexity
would not be a very interesting idea
some concept of universality
all right now another fact
the maximal complexity
of a system of n qubits
is exponential in n
4 to the n
talking about now the complexity of
unitary operators
we could talk about state complexity
then it would be 2 to the n
uh the maximal complexity
of a circuit or maximal complexity of a
state
is exponential in n
and once you reach that exponential
value
the complexity stops increasing
you can continue to run the circuit
run more and more gates but you will
always find that that same final state
could be accomplished
with fewer gates than you used you never
need more than four to the n
i'll also assume
that the complexity grows according to a
particular rule
namely that it grows linearly
for a long period of time linearly and
proportional to the number of qubits
and then it grows until it reaches the
maximum
and then stops growing
these are all fairly familiar ideas um
to what extent they proved or not proved
i won't get into here
their assumptions
finally
black holes
are fairly conventional chaotic quantum
systems for which all of this stuff
applies
all right now i want to come to
an issue that was raised
in 2013
by a group known as the amps group el
mari maroff bolchinsky and sully
and
i'm not going to get deeply into the
issue of firewalls but i'm just going to
make write down one statement
that was made in the context of the amps
firewall paradox
and only one statement the claim was
that the generic quantum states of a
black hole
have firewalls
now a firewall to me doesn't really mean
a wall of fire
it means a firewall in the sense of an
obstruction to information entering the
black hole
entering behind the horizon of the black
hole
the black hole is a firewall in the
sense of an obstruction to information
entering it
that was the claim
generic quantum states
but what did they mean the important
issue here is what did they mean
by a generic state
i'm only using the amp story here
to pull out the word generic
what is the nature what is the meaning
of generic quantum state
is it a state which is thermalized or in
other words which has run long enough
chaotically to behave thermally
well that takes a very short amount of
time
thermal equilibrium is established for a
system very rapidly
certainly in polynomial time
more likely time of order one
is it scrambled scrambled is a fancier
version of thermalized which takes a
little bit longer in which information
is really absorbed into the system in a
way that's very difficult to extract
is it scrambled
is it thermalized
the amps people assumed
that a thermalized or scrambled state
was generic generic quantum state
well then comes the question are black
holes in nature generic
i'm going to now explain to you
why a generic quantum state is very very
far
from what is ordinarily meant by thermal
or
scrambled
or anything that can be produced in a
reasonable length of time
here's an example of hidden order
that's present in a quantum system for a
very very long period of time
let's see
imagine a quantum state of a chaotic
system which is evolving in time here's
the standard rule for the evolution of a
quantum state in time
let's suppose the size of i's here are
real numbers just for simplicity
and let's also suppose that the energy
spectrum
is bounded from below and in fact
bounded from below at zero
then these phases here are all that vary
with time
their phases they move on a unit circle
at time t equals zero they're all at the
same point
namely
one
and as the system evolves the individual
phases start one so winding around the
circle
the velocity is proportional to
velocity is the energy of the particular
state and so they're all like a snake
like a um like a worm they start to
spread out over here
and it doesn't take very long
for them to for the first leading edge
of the worm over here to completely
circumnavigate the circle
why
because
leading edge here is determined by the
highest energy state
it takes a small amount of time to go
around
and then it keeps going around and it
keeps going around
now to show you what this hidden order
is
let's consider neighboring states by
neighboring states i mean they have
neighboring energies
neighboring meaning closest nearest
neighbor in energy
what happens to the distance between
them as time goes on well of course it
grows
but it grows for a very long time and
remain small for a very long time
because the energy levels are so close
this means that for example if you were
to look after a fair amount of time
at the sequence of
um
phases here one two three the first one
second one the third one the fourth one
and so forth
they would form a sequence
which was be very recognizable you would
after a time you would see perhaps
one over here two over here three over
here now of course there may be things
in between if the worm had traveled all
around the circle here a few times there
will be things in between but you will
still find that one is close to two two
is close to three three is close to four
and so forth
for a long time
how long a time the time would be the
time that it would take for two
neighboring energy levels one and two to
separate by something like the
circumference of the circle
2 pi
a small fraction of 2 pi but a small
fraction of order 1.
once that happens
the ordering of the levels gets all
mixed up on here
one four two five three and so forth
in other words after a period
the
sequence or the order
and what i mean now the order of levels
gets all mixed up
and difficult
to uh very difficult to become
pseudo-random if you like
how long does that take it takes a time
of order e to the entropy of the system
that's because the neighboring energy
levels have a distance between them e to
the minus the entropy
and so it takes a time of order e to the
entropy for this order
this recognizable order to disappear
this is long long long beyond the time
that it takes to thermalize
and so there is some measure of
randomness
that grows long past thermalization
or you could say it the other way
there is some measure of order
which decreases or which decays the
times long past thermalization
generosity true generosity of a quantum
state
only occurs after exponentially long
times
so what amps was thinking
omari and company
that had a state became generic
after a thermalization time or a
scrambling time is not at all true the
state still has a great deal of order
and that was part of the resolution of
this firewall paradox i don't want to
get into the firewall paradox i simply
wanted to point out
that there is hidden order in quantum
states that last for a very long time
exponentially long
all right let's move on to something
else now which is going to come up
the er equals epr idea er here stands
for einstein rosenbridge einstein rosen
wormhole otherwise known as a wormhole
epr well that you're probably very
familiar with
that's einstein podolski and rosen and
it stands for entanglement
incidentally in the original epr paper i
think epr actually stood for elements of
physical reality
but we all recognize it as einstein
podelski and rosen
and i simply want to just quickly go
through the idea
that in some sense these two ideas are
the same there was this of course does
not appear in the 1935 papers of
einstein rosen podolski and so forth
there was no connection whatever made
between entanglement
and wormholes this is something that
came later
but let's just discuss what it means
the bent over sheet here that's just
supposed to be space and i've bent it
over just for convenience
you'll see what i mean in a moment
let's suppose
in one region we have a bunch of
particles and another region very far
away
we have another set of particles a dust
cloud a pair of dust clouds of particles
and these particles are allowed to
collapse into black holes incidentally
these particles have never seen each
other they've never talked to each other
one group is often alpha centauri the
other is in uh
brooklyn i don't know where and
they've never seen each other they've
never spoken to each other they've never
interacted with each other
the particles may have interacted with
each other but the ones on the top have
not interacted with the ones on the
bottom
and then they are allowed
to undergo gravitational collapse to
make black holes
this is my picture of a black hole
uh
not important uh that be realistic
they
collapse to form two black holes the two
black holes are completely disconnected
from each other and have no particular
relationship to each other
now let's compare that with another
thing
the next thing is let's start with
entangled pairs the green lines here
just indicate
maximal entanglement
maximum entanglement let's say between
the spins or between anything any
degrees of freedom describing the
particles
now there's no way
that you can have that kind of
entanglement unless at some point the
particles did interact with each other
so what you should what you should
imagine is that it all started out near
each other
entangled
and then
separated
into two two subsets
of entangled particles
now let the entangled particles
undergo gravitational
collapse
gravitational collapse of this subset
and gravitational collapse of that
subset
that again creates two black holes
but now according to the er equals epr
hypothesis
they create a pair of black holes with a
wormhole connecting them
that's the er equals epr hypothesis it's
well tested
uh
i was rather surprised when juan
maldener and i first put this idea out
that people accepted it as quickly as
they did but they did and it's now a
well-recognized um
part
of
quantum gravity if you like er equals
epr
as i said what it means is if you create
a pair of black holes by collapsing
entangled particles the black holes will
have spatial connectivity
between here and here they will be
connected by a wormhole
now i'm going to
jump
well i'm not really jumping i'm just
describing this wormhole here in another
way
by a penrose diagram i am aware of the
fact that a fraction of the audience
doesn't know very much about gravity
and doesn't know very much about general
relativity or black holes
i'm going to ignore that fact
but i'm going to try to explain things
in a way which is reasonably
self-contained
so that hopefully you'll get the idea of
how a penrose diagram works
the left side
incidentally
here my two black holes are one on top
of the other they're related vertically
here they're related horizontally i
think i can fix this just a moment let
me fix this
there now my black holes are related
horizontally
left black hole right black hole
entangled
this is the penrose diagram that goes
with that particular kind of pair of
black holes
which are entangled and therefore
connected by a wormhole
the left side
this is the exterior
of the left black hole
the region out here the exterior
here's the exterior of the right black
hole
out here
and
here is the interior of the black hole
in fact it's the it's the wormhole
itself
the wormhole is the region in between
is the wormhole
forget the bottom half of the diagram
for a moment
and the various things you need to know
about this
is the top edge of the diagram is the
singularity
the left edge over here and the right or
the left edge and the right edge
correspond to the location of the
holographic degrees of freedom
describing these black holes and now you
can ask
what about the region outside these two
black holes in which you can imagine
moving around from one to the other
well that's not drawn here but you can
think of it as
the penrose diagram being embedded in a
bigger space which allows you to move
around the long way
the wormhole is moving the short way
it goes through here
and
you can also go the long way
all right now i i'm quite aware that
this is um
at best very hazy for those who have
never
studied black holes
but let's keep going let's see what all
this means
first of all
the exterior of the black holes
are in fact completely static
this doesn't look static here it looks
like um
well it looks like this time depend
these are time slices here
time slices look like this
constant radius from the center of the
black hole looks like this
and the diagram is drawn in such a way
the most important thing is that light
rays move on 45 degree angles
that's the most important thing
okay
for better or worse i will assume
that you have some rough idea of what
this picture is representing
again another important thing is that
what's going on in the exterior of the
black holes is completely static
this point is like this point is like
this point is like this point is like
this point
completely static with no time evolution
going on
from the point of view of the exterior
observer over here or the exterior
observer over here
all right here's a picture of somebody
jumping into the black hole
the purple line here that's the
trajectory of bob bob is always the
fellow who jumps into the black hole
from the right side
bob jumps in eventually hits the
singularity is a bit suicidal to do so
uh
crosses the horizon over here now what
sense is this the horizon over here
it's clear that anybody who passes this
point
cannot get out without exceeding the
speed of light
cannot get out and escape back out to
the exterior regions
that's what the horizon is a point of no
return
once you've crossed it you can't get
back out
so bob when he crosses the horizon
is inevitably doomed to hit the
singularity
all right one thing that can happen with
these entangled black holes
remember one is off on alpha centauri
the other is in brooklyn
alice on her side
and bob on his side can each jump into
their black holes let's go back to the
earlier picture
that means
alice jumping in from here
bob jumping in from here
and as you can see
it's potentially possible for them to
meet
in a very short amount of time
even if the black holes are very very
far apart
alice and bob can meet shake hands do
whatever it is that alice and bob do
however
as i said it's somewhat suicidal
romeo and juliet will soon
expire at the singularity
but what is impossible
is for a signal in particular a signal
that they met over here or any other
signal that began behind the horizon to
get out into the exterior region
no
classically as a classical statement
no message can escape from behind the
horizon this is the behind the horizon
region
okay that's really all we need to know
well no it's not all we need to know we
need to know a little more
one other point as i said
the exterior regions here
are static
in fact they are in thermal equilibrium
[Music]
the fact that the two sides are
entangled
means
that if you integrate it out in other
words if you traced over one side
the other side would be in some
non-trivial density matrix
in this setup
the density matrix of each side when
traced out over the other side is
perfectly thermal
and in fact is in thermal equilibrium
now let's jump ahead to the next
observation
i told you that the exterior regions are
perfectly static
but if you look at this diagram it's
completely obvious
that the interior region behind the
horizons i'm not at all static in fact
that region is growing with time
its volume
is growing linearly with time
something is going on in this system
here
which is growing linearly with time
even though
from the point of view of the exterior
of the black holes
the systems are in perfect thermal
equilibrium
nevertheless something is growing
and it's possible to argue reasonably
that this growth will go on for a very
long exponentially long period of time
we don't need to think about these
two-sided entanglement entangled black
holes to make the point
for those who recognize the penrose
diagram for a black hole formed by the
collapse of a star
this is the material of the star
it collapses eventually forms a
singularity
and here's the horizon
if you recognize it
will mean something to you
um
we follow the horizon
the horizon grows
according to the rules of quantum
gravity the growth of the horizon
means that the entropy
of the black hole or the entropy of the
configuration is growing
it's growing because the star is
collapsing and as it collapses
the entropy grows
but it stops growing right over here at
this point
the area of the horizon simply becomes
constant
and
the entropy of the black hole
stops growing
it becomes static
perfectly static
and in thermal equilibrium
on the other hand if you look at this
penrose diagram you will see that the
region behind the horizon is growing
it's growing and it grows for a very
long time
something grows linearly with time long
after thermal equilibrium is established
that of course should remind you of what
i said earlier
that there's a subtle kind of hidden
order in quantum systems that can
evolve a long long times past thermal
equilibrium
incidentally this idea was something of
a shock to most physicists
that
thermal equilibrium is not the end of
the line for quantum evolution
whatever it is
whatever represents whatever quantum
thing represents this growth here
is very hard to feel from the outside
i'm using the term feel now
in a sense that was i to my knowledge
coined
by um
adam boland
bill fefferman and uh and um
uh umesh
we'll come back to what feel means in a
little while
but it's very difficult to feel
in the sense that what's going on out
here is practically in perfect thermal
equilibrium
and very hard to detect this very spine
this very uh fine spun
thing
this fine spun order this unfeelable
order
and i'll come to what unfeelable means
in a moment
but what is this quantity what is this
quantity which continues to grow
my answer was
that about the only thing that it could
be
is quantum circuit complexity
that's quantum circuit complexity was
the obvious candidate for something
which grows long long after thermal
equilibrium
it's a very fine spun quantity difficult
to detect
but
but it exists it exists and it grows
if we were to
look at the evolution of quantum
complexity now this is something of a
conjecture
some parts of it have been proved
some
versions of it have improved in various
kinds of toy models
the complexity as a function of time
grows linearly as you lay down gates
the complexity simply grows linearly the
number of gates it took to get that
state grows linearly until it saturates
it saturates when the complexity reaches
the maximum possible value and then it
simply is constant with small
fluctuations
that still is something of a um of a
conjecture
but i think at least in part it has been
proved for some simple systems and i
will assume it of course
if you were to take a microscope not a
microscope a magnifying glass and lay it
down over here you would find that the
thermalization time the conventional
thermalization time
was a tiny tiny fraction
a tiny fraction of the time spent
during which the complexity was growing
i would say that any state
it doesn't matter whether it's a black
hole or a quantum computer or whatever
it happens to be
uh
if it's a chaotic system
will follow something like this we'll
follow a complexity evolution something
like this
where
most of the time most of the observable
time
is spent during this this period of
increase
it takes very very long for it to reach
the generic behavior
which does in fact last for a much
longer time
but
generic is up here
linearly growing is over here and
anything you can make in the laboratory
or in astronomy or any other reasonable
situation
will
lie somewhere along this growing region
so black holes in nature would be
expected to be in this growing region
here
okay when i put this idea out
that
the thing that was growing
in the interior of a black hole was
quantum complexity
it met with uh two pretty much distinct
um
uh
reactions
from the quantum gravity community i'll
call it the ifq the it from cubic meters
everybody seemed happy with that okay
complexity equals volume
volume of the wormhole there was very
little resistance to it
people started making calculations all
over the place
some of the calculations were very
interesting
uh some
calculations of what calculation of the
growth of the volume of the interior of
black holes
uh but didn't ask very hard questions
about this
largely just accepted it
i was surprised
on the other hand from the
complexity theoretic
community the reaction was different
although very polite
it basically was no you can't be right
that must be wrong
that's crazy
at least two of the people that i
remember
are reacting
again politely
but reacting that way with scott
and adam scott berenson and adam boland
i told the story at one point to umesh
very early on
and umesh is very very polite and kind
and generous
but i could see in his eye
skepticism
why the skepticism
and the reason
is because quantum complexity is
unfeelable
that was the term as i said that was
coined by buland uh
um
fefferman
almost am i right
that that term was coined by you guys
let me show you there
uh yeah yeah
hi yeah that's terrible right
yeah
and uh at first i thought the word
unfeelable was a little bit too
peculiar but i've come to think that
unfeelable is exactly the right word to
describe
the
fine spun nature of quantum complexity
so
what does it mean that the quantum
complexity is unfeelable
well first of all it means that it's
uncomputable and unmeasurable well not
quite uncomputable
when i mean uncomputable here i mean
uncomputable in the practical sense
um
that it's exponentially difficult
i'll i'll
i'll um
come to that in a moment
but
that in practice that it is uncomputable
and unmeasurable
impossible not quite impossible but
almost impossible to tell the difference
between very moderate amounts of
complexity
and exponentially large amounts of
complexity
it's unfeelable it's uncalculable it's
unmeasurable
and here's an example
of the sense in which that's true
let's suppose i gave you a quantum state
now by saying i gave you a quantum state
i literally mean
uh i give you a system in that quantum
state i may even give you the system and
a polynomial number of um
of replica of replicas of the system
and i promise you that a or is true
a
the complexity of the state psi
is a certain number c
which we can assume is polynomial for
the moment polynomial in the number of
qubits
modest
even small
well
and
numerically large but small by compared
with the maximal complexity
or b the complexity of psi is maximal
that the state psi is a completely
generic
maximally complex state
and i tell you it's one of the other
what is the computational complexity of
distinguishing a from b this is not
asking what the complexity of a or b is
it's asking what is the complexity of
distinguishing
a from b
call that
the complexity of complexity
the complexity of determining how
complex a state is
i call it cc
well it turns out there's only one real
one
procedure
for measuring the complexity of a state
or in this case of distinguishing a from
b
and it basically consists our circle
here is supposed to be the space of
states uh the unit ball the unit of the
unit sphere
space of states
of the n qubit system
technically it's uh cp 2 to the n minus
1 or something basically a sphere
this is the space of states
here's a simple state
let's say completely unentangled state
here's the state psi in question
how do you compute or how do you how do
you um determine what the complexity is
the answer is basically you try all
possible circuits
circuit here here's a here's a gate
there's another gate here's another gate
here's another gate you simply try all
possible
circuits sequence of gates
of length c
and see whether you hit the target state
the shortest such sequence there are
many such sequences which in fact
eventually almost anything we'll get see
the shortest such sequence
is the
of c here
but in order to test what the complexity
is
there's really no alternative then
basically trying all possible
uh
circuits until you hit that point
until you hit that point and check that
it was the minimal one
how many such circuits are there or how
many such trajectories are there
sequences of uh gates
of length c the answer is e to the c
the number of
trajectories of number of circuits
of length c
length meaning the number of gates in
them is e to the c
and so that what that tells us
is that the complexity of complexity the
complexity of knowing the complexity
is itself exponential and c now c could
be relatively small
c could be polynomial it could be a
thousand
so it could be a million that's that's
small by comparison with anything we're
really interested in e to the c is not
small
so this is the sense
in which
determining the complexity or the
complexity is unfeel you can't
efficiently calculate it
even if it's relatively small
to calculate it
is a very very difficult
exponentially difficult problem
and you can't efficiently measure it
if that's true
if it is that fine spun
that unfeelable how can it possibly be
related to anything physical
that i think was the complaint
that the people who really knew about
complexity
had about the idea
that complexity could be representing
the physical property of the size of the
interior of the black hole
it led
various people
i know that scott used the term or
something like it adam used the term
it must be some sort of pseudo
complexity it can't be genuine
complexity
that uh that is
really measuring
the size of the interior of the black
hole
it must be some
pseudo complexity something that behaves
like complexity but is not really
complexity something more feelable
uh
my answer to that
was don't be so surprised that
don't be so surprised by the unfeel
ability of whatever it is
that that's
determining the size of the interior of
the black hole
the interior of the black hole is also
very unfeelable
unfeelable from the outside
remember that all during this growth of
the interior of the black hole
the outsides of the black hole the
outsides of the wormhole are in perfect
thermal equilibrium or close to perfect
thermal equilibrium
and this is very difficult to detect
what's going on on the interior
so really there's no real contradiction
there
both are very unfeelable that was my
answer i don't think it sat it was
completely satisfactory and certainly
didn't satisfy um
the complexity theorists
i can stop here for a question uh too if
anybody wants to
okay i'll go on
come on the scene bouland
peppermint and vasarani who i believe at
the time when they started the project
were trying to demonstrate
that complexity could not be what's
going on in the interior of the black
hole for all the reasons that i said
they invented a particular
protocol
uh which goes something like this
here's your two side here's your
two-sided black hole i don't think they
were terribly specific about whether
you're talking about a two-sided black
hole
two black holes or one black hole this
wasn't terribly important
and let's imagine now
um
waiting
is time t equals zero let's see here is
time t equals zero whoops right over
here when the black hole was created
it evolves for a period of time
upward
and at some later time
we are given the state of the black hole
somebody's given the state of the black
hole and what do they ask they are asked
how big given the state
they are asked to determine
how big at that time the wormhole is
okay
now in general that is not
too hard
because you can evolve if you know the
hamiltonian if you know the hamiltonian
you can evolve the system backward in
time for a period
see how long it takes for you to get
back
to the simple state to the simple
initial state
and if you know how long it took
then you know how big the wormhole is
well
bulan fefferman and bazarani wanted to
avoid
that situation and so they said let's
throw in randomly or pseudo-randomly
a
collection of perturbations
the first perturbation at this time
wait a scrambling time perturb it again
wait a scrambling time perturb it again
those perturbations send in
waves or particles or whatever and we're
going to do this somewhat randomly in
the following sense
the perturbation that we send in could
be one of two possibilities let's call
them u and v
but we're going to arrange them randomly
and we're not going to tell we're going
to keep secret
what the sequence of perturbations were
we'll keep that secret in our pocket
and not give it to bob and alice bob and
alice later are going to be asked to
reconstruct
from the state over here
what the length of the wormhole is
that's a hard problem
that's a hard problem
in the sense that if you don't have the
ability to run the system backward you
simply have to
learn what what it is
by using the dictionary
connecting the quantum mechanics to
gravity
how hard is that
well if there are ill random
perturbations
then the answer is the
complexity point of view
the complexity of knowing the complexity
of the state
is again exponential of order two to the
l or bigger
in other words even if l is modest
even if the system has only been about
to evolve
for a relatively short amount of time it
is still extremely hard to tell what the
output is
from a completely maximally random state
uh
that was the mazarani construction
and
it indicated
just how hard it is to reconstruct
information about the interior of a
black hole
from
knowledge or from being presented with
the actual quantum states
another way to say it is whatever the
volume is here
it is very unfeelable from the outside
okay now what the authors then said
is surely the volume of the wormhole is
feelable
we've proved
that the complexity
of the state
is very unfeelable
but surely the volume of the wormhole is
feelable
well no it's actually not but for a
reason which is somewhat irrelevant
the reason that it's not that it's not
feelable
is
because uh once it gets a little bit too
late
no observer who can observe a point over
here
can also observe a point over here or a
point over here it's not really possible
to measure the entire for any given
observer to measure the whole length of
the wormhole
but that's not really relevant that's
not relevant to the way that uh that
omission company
phrased the uh the argument
here's what they said their argument was
more subtle and got around this issue
that you can't really measure the uh
the volume of the wormhole
let's assume
that the dictionary relating the quantum
mechanics
of the boundary
of the black hole the adscft dictionary
that's the quantum
gravity dictionary let's assume that
it's efficient
efficient meaning
that if you're given the state psi
in a sub
exponential time sub exponential number
of steps
you can
predict
what the metric is
in the interior of the black hole
given psi
you can then
calculate efficiently under the
assumption
that the dictionary is efficient
you can compute the volume of the
wormhole here it is
given the state here and given that the
dictionary between exterior and interior
is efficient
you can calculate the
volume of that wormhole
just by integrating
the metric and that's not very hard
integrating it up numerically or whoever
however you want to do it
and so it would seem that the volume of
the interior is feelable
and easy
to
compute if
the dictionary is simple if the
dictionary is efficient
what it will mean for the dictionary to
not be efficient is almost that it's
useless
if the dictionary is not efficient
it's practically useless
it would mean that to make any
prediction about the interior is an
exponentially difficult problem
knowing about the quantum state of the
system
all right but if complexity and the
volume of the interior are really the
same thing then there is a problem
c the complexity is unfeelable for the
reasons that i said
but the volume appears to be feelable
how can they be the same thing
the conclusion is one of two things
either the quantum extended church
turing
thesis
is wrong in this context
in other words that there is a physical
way
of
measuring or determining or computing
they're all the same thing in a quantum
context
the
the volume of the interior
that the volume of the interior is
expected to be feelable and easy to
compute
on the other hand
the quantum
complexity theory would tell us that
it's very very hard
to compute
the complexity
that's a mismatch
either
the quantum e c t t is wrong in this
context
or the dictionary must be exponentially
complex itself
even for relatively uncomplex signi
i believe this is correct i believe the
argument is correct
but i would like to try to do better
i see i'm running out of time but i'll
try to get to the point as quickly as
possible
can we do better than bfv
and doing better here would mean that we
construct a situation where bob can
actually solve an exponentially hard
problem
in a short time by actually jumping into
the black hole
that was not possible in the case of the
volume of the interior because it just
was too not possible to measure the
whole volume of the interior
but i think the answer is yes we can
construct an example
this is an example
of a
of a problem that i think can be solved
by jumping into the black hole
whereas other methods would be
exponentially difficult
here's the setup
am i uh am i uh do i have a few more
minutes oh yeah yeah that's fine oh good
excellent
excellent
good
all right here's what we're gonna do
we're not going to just send in the uh
the um the signals
that omission company invented to sort
of blur
what's going on between t equals zero
and the time we actually do our
measurements
blur it or randomize it
we're going to do something first before
that
we're going to
put in a signal
very early on now but to split the
signal in very early on
what we have to imagine is that we can
run our system backward
run our black hole or run our
simulating system
backward for a time
apply a perturbation
and then run it forward again
would correspond to putting in a
perturbation in the past
and let's suppose that perturbation is
one of two types
it could be they could be distinguished
for example this could be a photon
being sent into the uh into the wormhole
and the photon could have one of two
polarization states
either a or b
or it could be an electron or a muon or
whatever we like some distinction
between a and b
which is quite feelable
easy to tell the difference between an
electron and muon
but now what happens
is this perturbation starts to fall into
the black hole as it falls into the
black hole it is blue shifted this is
simply the statement that its energy
increases as it falls into the black
hole
and by the time it gets to the horizon
its energy is huge
its energy is huge and this has become a
very dangerous shock wave for anybody
who would fall in at this time over here
the perturbation falls in becomes a
shock wave and then continues on its way
through the wormhole
and eventually gets to the singularity
of course as it comes up out of the
black hole
or as it comes back up out
it loses energy so it goes in becomes a
very intense shock wave and then climbs
back out
eventually it's the singularity over
here it doesn't get to the outside but
by the time it gets over here it's
fairly benign and its energy is very low
okay
what is the problem that we want to
solve
we want
from the point of view of knowing the
quantum state at a later time being
handed this quantum state at a later
time
bob's or is it alice i'm not sure or
maybe jointly
they're going to try to figure out
whether we sent in a or b
that's the problem a or b
well
in this context
a or b
in particular if we've
randomized the state
by sending in these waves over here
a or b will be very unfeelable from the
outside
why
because the sequence of perturbations
here makes the state quite
indistinguishable from a maximally
complex state in a maximally complex
state you certainly can't tell the
difference between whether you sent in a
or b easily
so it's expected that this problem
i won't get deeply into it but it's
expected this problem is a hard problem
hard problem in the sense that it's
exponentially difficult
in the number of
um
perturbations that were created whose
only purpose was to obscure and make it
make the problem difficult
okay so that's the problem
how can it be solved
here i've sort of focused in on the
corner over here what's going on
shock wave comes in starts to lose
energy
and as it comes in it becomes rather
benign in fact it turns back into a
photon
a low energy photon for example of
either a or b type in fact it remembers
what type was sent in over here
it comes out over here either a or b
and bob is now going to solve the
problem
by simply jumping into the black hole
i will jump into the black hole
very easily detect whether
the green particle
is a or b
and therefore will have solved what is a
very difficult computational problem
by simply jumping into the black hole
sounds a bit crazy
but uh
and this is essentially the
b f
v
idea
but construct it in such a way that an
observer can really jump in
and determine the answer to the problem
so bob easily beats the quantum
extended church
touring
thesis but of course at the cost of
being rather suicidal
and at the cost of not being able to
ever get the uh the information
out
so he has
learned what he wanted to learn
but in a sense
it's useless information
at least useless from the outside of a
black hole here's a quantum circuit
which represents basically the same
thing i did
the two sides of the quantum circuit are
representing the two black holes
uh
they're based they're two entangled
quantum computers if you like entangled
in the thermal field double space
thermal field double state just means a
state of high entanglement
the two quantum computers
uh
let's not get into the details of the
architecture of the quantum computers
and over here there is a um
a
gate it's not a single it's not a two
cubic gate it's a complicated gate
and it represents
going backward
perturbing the system and going forward
again
by a sequence of operator but
it's just a complicated gate
which does the same thing
as on this penrose diagram running
backward perturbing and going forward
i just illustrate this to say
there is a quantum there is a quantum
circuit version of this
what about bob jumping into the black
hole
bob jumping into the black hole could
simply be
bob who is after all a bunch of qubits
merging with the quantum computer and
then being scrambled into the quantum
computer
uh
what
this story what the black hole story is
telling us is that in some sense
when bob has merged into the quantum
computer here
he can gain knowledge
of a versus b
that would be very very hard
for somebody who stayed on the outside
we can imagine the following scenario
this is bob again
bob doesn't jump in himself he sends in
bob prime
bob prime is uh is a drone drone bob
we send drone bob in
drone bob
goes into the interior of the computer
makes whatever measurements which are
not very difficult measurements
and uh and determines
a versus b
or at least that's what the black hole
is telling us
is possible
he learns a b very fast the problem is
he can't get the information bob prime
can't get the information back out to
bob
so this suggests
a version
of the quantum let's call it the quantum
gravity extended church during case of
thesis
that it actually applies only to
observers who remain outside the horizon
of the black hole
and not observers who fall through the
horizon in other words
we're accepting the idea i accept the
idea
that bob can learn this kind of
forbidden information at the cost of
jumping through the horizon
but
that to get that information out
to a conventional observer on the
outside
of the uh of the process
bob who remains outside that that in
itself is exponentially difficult
this suggests a new kind of meaning to
the horizon of a black hole
the properties of the horizon
the difficulty of getting information
out past the horizon once it's inside
is the thing which protects
the
the
q-g-e-c-t
there's another t at the end of this
isn't there
thesis
it's the properties of the horizon
itself which protects bob on the outside
from ever gaining
information which would violate the uh
the thesis
[Music]
okay that's that's that sounds somewhat
trivial but it leads to some uh some
basic um
uh conjectures
for example
it tells us
or it suggests that the
computational complexity
of extracting a certain kind of
information from the interior of the
black hole
is in this case at least two to the l
we should be able to prove
uh either in the gravitational context
or the computer circuit context
in particular in the gravitational
context
that any protocol which extracts
information from the interior of a black
hole
in this case
will require a complexity of at least
two to the l
to extract out the information that bob
himself got so easily
now there's lots of info there's lots of
evidence that something like this is
true
that it is that hard to get information
out from a black hole it's not
impossible
it is that hard for example
you can extract out information by
letting the black hole evaporate
um but there's lots of information lots
of um
evidence
that
it is exponentially difficult to extract
that information
the question is is there a match
is there a match between what the
quantum computation quantum complexity
theory says the difficulty is
and
what the application of these various
protocols to the gravitational system is
but what i find most interesting
is the idea that there are new
complexity classes
in particular a new complexity class
that i call j i slash poly
j and i stand for jumping in
jumping in the black hole
it would consist of all problems which
can be solved internally in the quantum
computer
or better yet or in the black hole case
all problems which can be solved by bob
by jumping into the black hole
efficiently and quickly
but which presumably
require exponential effort to extract
the information out
uh
you might phrase it this way
a complexity class
which
involves
information or problems
which would be easy to solve if you
could summon a complexity genie a
complexity genie means a genie
which can once
invoke that genie once
the genie has the capacity in a small
amount of time of executing a highly
complex operation
an exponentially complex operation
the genie
you can tell the genie what
exponentially complex operation to do
the genie can do it quickly
but only once
what
are the class of problems
which are easy
if you can summon a complexity genie but
otherwise extremely difficult
i think that is something like that is
the complexity class
of problems which can be solved
by bob by jumping through the horizon of
the black hole
and
learning information
that is inaccessible from the outside
all of this is closely related to the to
the idea that um
buland peppermint and vasarani
said
namely
that
the dictionary between the inside and
the outside is exponentially difficult
you solve the problem internally in the
computer
or in the black hole but then getting it
back out is the difficult thing
so i think
the a b
um
example here
is an existence proof or at least if it
can be uh if it can be done
with more precision or enough precision
would be an existence proof
that this complexity class is non-empty
the complexity class j i poly
which in computer language would be the
complexity class of things which are
easy if you can summon the complexity
genie
but otherwise hard
okay i think i'm finished
great
well thank you very much for
there was a there was a really
stimulating talk uh i think there are a
few questions from the audience by the
way i wanted to say one thing i meant to
say i i did not decide to talk about the
subject because you invited me yeah i
had been thinking about this subject
along with scott and other people for a
while
and the fact that you just happened to
invite me was uh was more or less
accidental
no i i guess that's much uh no it's it's
this is fantastic uh it's really thought
provoking
um
i think you have a you have some
questions from other audience um
maybe we can we can do a couple of
questions before we move on to the panel
uh
i think uh
i'll leave the screen this way or should
i
maybe you can if you can stop sharing it
would be it would be helpful
i just promote
uh eli had a question i think i just
unmuted him yes thank you very much for
unmuting
me let me let me um let me reorganize my
uh
computer here just give me a second
all right now how do i do this um
i forget how to do this oops
okay and maybe we can have your
can we start uh lenny's
wait the host has asked you to start
your video okay
can you see me yes
and you can we can see the lower half of
your oh now we can see great yeah okay
all right
the problem is i can't write on the
computer if it's tilted vertical i need
it to be horizontal if it's horizontal
all you get to see is the ceiling in my
room
so
now we i i noticed the ceiling and by
the way what uh software were you
writing on
oh it's so
it's called notability it's very good
okay so i have a question
uh it and and it was a very stimulating
talk uh now
it seems to me that in physics there's
this idea we don't ask questions for
which there uh there's no answer
and uh anything past the event horizon
uh we're not supposed to know about no
so it seems to me that that
all the pictures that you have drawn
that are inside the event horizon are
totally optional and that you could have
arrived at the same conclusions without
invoking anything past the event horizon
do you have any comment on that yeah
yeah yeah i do um
the idea that nothing from behind her
event horizon can be extracted
is a classical idea
it is not thought to be true quantum
mechanically
it is just thought to be exponentially
difficult um
so
i i agree with that but it seems to me
that uh you could have made the the same
argument uh without uh going be behind
the event horizon for example
all the uh the photons falling into the
event horizon they get scrambled they
get squished uh and then it gets to be a
very difficult computation to
reconstruct them on their way out
wouldn't that pretty much say the same
thing without invoking uh something
inside the event horizon
well the point here is that uh
the the curious the curiosity that we're
pointing to
is that from all that we know about
general relativity quantum mechanics and
and their relationship
it appears that
an observer willing to jump into the
black hole can answer the question
easily and quickly
now you may or may not find that
interesting
uh
some people think no that can't be right
i think it's right
uh some people think well it could be
right but it's not interesting
i find it interesting
um but it also points as i said to a
complexity class of those problems which
can be solved in that way
and um
i think that complexity class can be
translated
into
quantum computational language
but it involves the existence of what i
call the complexity genie
so
that part i understand thank you
who are you anyway
uh this is uh eli yavalanovic from uc
berkeley okay all right oh did we meet
i think we met we're both the old-timers
so we've met at some point yeah i think
we did yeah
sorry uh seth did you want to ask a
question you were waiting oh i was just
waving at eli okay oh okay seth nice to
see you
i do have some questions for for for
lenny which was by the way was this a
super great talk um
and and uh
i'm confused about a couple of things i
don't know if can can somebody let me
show my screen here
is that okay
um okay
if you can keep it short because because
we should be moving up to the panel soon
so okay good we are running a bit late
good first of all i'd like to uh uh i'd
like to
here's this is you
some of you may notice this this is a
the cover of scientific american from
2004 by an article that i wrote about
black hole quantum computers
so uh talking about for people who
actually want to look at the actual
physics of how many operations you can
perform with stuff falling into a black
hole even though it's scientific
american it's a good article for that
i i'm sorry i'm sorry i shouldn't
advertise in that way but
i'm ready
uh then um but the my question i have
some questions so when i was learning
let me see if i can actually
share this other thing so i'm a little
confused about a couple of things
which
are this so can you see this right now
yeah i just redrew
a a a
this is the penrose diagram for the
uh
er wormhole it's also the same as the
candles diagram for the analytic
continuation of a black hole at least
this part right here um and i'm just
going to draw some lines that i saw
stephen hawking draw on these when i
took his quantum gravity course in 2004.
so i have an issue here i don't know if
you can see my point or maybe not
here's bob outside and here's bob's time
outside right here
and then here's alice over here and
here's here's her time out there but the
thing is that once you go through the
horizon right here which is this point
right here and this is of course the
light like future horizon but this is
what you see as a space the intersection
of your space like surface in the
horizon so what bob sees his time going
forward is for alice time going the
other way
so hold on just a second just let me
finish so when bob
falls into the black hole and goes into
this part of the interior of the
wormhole alice is going into a spatially
distinct part of the interior of the
wormhole and so they can't actually meet
each other can you comment on that i
mean i that doesn't make sense with what
steven was saying yeah yeah no i mean um
look the black hole isn't uh that
different than ordinary rindler space
yeah exactly imagine that you drew
window space
well you can there are various kinds of
time translation or various notions of
time that you can use
you can use
the time that you're drawing which i
call boost time i think everybody calls
it boost time or window
yeah yeah runs forward on the right and
backward on the left right like that i'm
just drawing your words okay but there's
also but there's also just good old
minkowski time which runs forward on
both sides
now
you get your choice you can you can use
whatever time you variable you like
but if we're really talking about the
situation
not of two completely disconnected
non-interacting worlds
but of two black holes which are simply
well separated
the example that i gave was uh particles
which were entangled
dragged apart they started close
together they were dragged apart they're
in the same universe time goes forward
in all parts of that universe
and then you collapse them to form two
black holes
then the natural time keeping is for
both times to go up okay good so that's
what i wanted to clarify so you're
saying in the picture you drew you get
two sets of entangled particles they go
way off in some place in these different
places and they collapse to form black
holes right and time on the on the
alice's side is going this way
yeah good so my other question that's
great that's a good clarification i i
accept that so the other one is that i'm
a little confused when you say about the
number of the actual volume is expanding
in this computation i mean i'm not sure
i agree that you know the
computation is
space-time volume but let's accept that
for the moment but the actual volume
here's here's now your picture of a
physical black hole you know the stellar
star collapses goes like this
it's the same penguin here's the
singularity up here here's the horizon
and there's a bunch of folks who fall
into this black hole and they're going
to do some kind of computation on the
way in
okay and they reach the singularity and
the time which for them in their proper
time is essentially on the order of the
radius of the black hole divided by
speed of light they can only interact
with you know actually a relatively
small fraction of the stuff that's
actually falling into the black hole
so that computation is actually not
expanding in time indeed if you were to
go and be if you look at the folks that
are falling to the black hole the
physical volumes up here are actually
much smaller in the space-like direction
than they are down here because they're
closed trapped surfaces so they're
contracting so i don't i don't
understand what you say that that i
understand there's an amount of
computation that goes on going into the
black hole but i don't understand what
you say that that you know you were
drawing these pictures where you go like
that say look it's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger but that's not the
computation experienced by the you know
the stuff that falls into the black hole
can can you comment on that
yeah that's exactly why that's exactly
why the volume cannot be measured
because any that's exactly why the
volume can't be measured
and therefore i didn't use volume i
didn't use the value of the volume
as the um
as
the computation
that's what
that's what omission company used as
their
um
goal the computation
knowledge of the volume
i think for every reason the reasons
that you say knowledge of the volume is
not feelable really
so they use another trick to make an
argument and the trick is i think the
right trick to say supposing um
supposing the dictionary is efficient
then they prove this contradiction
but um
i did not use that trick instead of
asking
to compute the volume
i
replaced it
by
computing whether it's a or b
now a or b come in from the left hand
side and move upward toward the right
so that they do move into the region
where bob can uh can see that
i don't have the picture in front of me
but uh well i remember it yeah it was a
great picture yeah i mean it's very
similar to this right like bob sends in
stuff right here here's the rest of
computation
but i guess the point is these folks
inside this computation ends at the
singularity the space like singularity
at which point they don't really have
any chance to communicate with each
other so i guess my last question is if
the computation
let me let me insist
that is exactly why i didn't use that as
uh the uh the interesting thing to try
to compute
that's also why
also why it was necessary to use the
two-sided black hole
to send in a message from the left which
would ultimately appear way up on the
right-hand side in the right-hand corner
and um be accessible to bob as he fell
in
um
so so thanks thanks millions millions of
questions it's a wonderful talk i really
i will i will get in touch with you
outside of this and catch up because i
have many more questions after your
wonderful talk beautifully done great
thanks uh thanks seth that was really
those are great questions i think we
should uh we should move on to the panel
which everybody's waiting for quite
eagerly so
if you can have the videos of the
panelists
pinned
um hello edward
great
it's
a it's a real
pleasure to introduce the panelists it's
an incredibly distinguished uh panel so
ed uh
i think is um you know he's a much
decorated and legendary figure in both
math and
and in physics um he uh he played a
central role in
in uh the development of string theory
through the mid 80s mid 90s uh
he's obviously he's also a field
medalist
um
jeff bennington uh from uh from berkeley
uh sorry uh edwardson is at the
institute for advanced studies uh jeff
pennington uh from berkeley he's uh
uh
he he did the first derivation
via gravity calculation to show that
black holes return information to the
outside
and then scott aronson everybody here
knows i think
for all his work on computation he's
joined us as a panelist many times at
speaker many times but i think what's
relevant for today is that
he he really is somebody who lives this
computational
lens on the science on physics
so he he understands
you know
enough physics to speak meaningfully
between between complexity theory and
physics so uh really great to have all
of you here and
it would be great to um
to
have your
you know your reactions to lenny's talk
or anything you want to add in
in any order that you'd like
in full disclosure i should say that all
these people have good friends of mine
that uh
edward i've been interacting with and
having physics discussions with for
probably more than 40 years
uh
and i've written papers all three of
them come to think of it
so
hi guys
hi
hi
nice talk
thank you
you and i have been talking about this
subject we have been we have been yes
probably for about five years or
something
at least
is it you you want you want me to start
jeffy i jeff and i have had a lot of fun
with snakes
yes
and their lunches right yeah but i think
i think it actually comes into this
issue here too
it does it does wow
i think scott was saying in the chat he
was going to explain what he thinks j i
slash point
j i slash power yeah that's not really
uh uh idiomatic naming complexity
classes but that's okay no i i would
like to define this thing and understand
what is or isn't in it but um you know
lenny i was very um i'm fascinated by
the the history that you recounted in
your talk and especially you know the
the hidebound complexity theoretic
establishment i guess
represented
that was not the message it was
conveying yeah what i was conveying was
the opposite i thought that the
physicists were a little too uh quick to
uh to bind
that would be that would be a a
different way to tell that story but you
know so so um well any
and my uh
first contact you know i don't know how
well you remember it lenny but it was
when he invited me to give a talk at the
string theory seminar at stanford in
2006
and i talked about something that i
thought would be just completely radical
you know
i didn't even know how well it would go
over right that uh
that you know high energy physicists
should uh have some knowledge of
computational complexity because if for
example a physical theory implied that
you could solve np-complete problems
with only you know polynomial effort
then you know that that could be seen as
an inherent problem for the theory
i remember it i remember it extremely
well
okay well you know much like if it if it
predicted you know super luminal
signaling or things like that because
you know what what people should
understand is that this is not just a
technical question of you know solving
optimization problems a little bit
faster right this is really about
automating mathematical creativity
itself uh you know can you just find a
proof of the riemann hypothesis in zf
set theory you know if such an object
exists uh and just you know pluck it out
from you know the whole you know space
of possibilities right and and uh in in
in as you know in only as much time as
would be needed to write it down right
this is this is the kind of thing that
we're talking about um
um you know but then um
around 2013 2014 probably you know uh
lenny himself you know got interested in
complexity theory um um and and yeah and
and ironically became much more gung-ho
about its relevance to physics than i
had ever been right and started saying
you know not just that it's relevant but
that circuit complexity is this
fundamental quantity in in you know in
in ads cft right and and i was then in
the bizarre position of saying well you
know let's uh slow down a bit right you
know how could it be a fundamental
quantity right i mean uh uh you know for
one thing there are different versions
of circuit complexity there's you know
with ancillary qubits without ancilla
cubits right if we don't even know which
one you know how can we pick one and you
know elevate it to the to the a similar
status to to entropy or whatever uh but
i i would say that that by now because
of lenny's work because of you know um
harlow and hayden and bowen fefferman
vasarani and you know and and jeff
pennington and a whole bunch of you know
others i i would consider it uh
established at this point that um
uh that that uh uh you know like when
when you ask about how do you decode
information from the hawking radiation
you know about the in-falling matter
right or when you ask uh you know what
is you know how does the ads cft
dictionary work right these questions
have a complexity theoretic flavor to
them right you know and that that is
something that is inherent you know
that's not just an artifact of the way
that we're thinking about them right now
i mean you know you can view be you know
bfv as essentially saying that and you
know i guess there's this new argument
as sort of a sharpened version of that
um so so now you know regarding the the
physical plausibility of you know
lenny's proposal to you know sort of
learn the answer to a computational
problem by jumping into a black hole and
then you know uh you know uh um you know
i guess you know
valuing truth about one specific
computational problem you know
over over your own life you know and and
your and your ability to share that
answer with anybody else right so you
know i'm going to leave it to my
extremely distinguished uh fellow
panelists to comment more you know on
the on the physical uh uh plausibility
of the proposal you know and and uh you
know uh
you know what what about the back
reaction and you know and would this
actually work right uh i i what i wanted
to do is comment on the you know maybe a
computer science aspect of this
challenge to the quantum extended church
touring thesis because because that is
what it is right that's that's what
we're talking about now you know one of
the most basic you know if annoying
things that we learn in computer science
uh is that the complexity of a problem
can depend radically on just how the
input is given to you
right so you know i mean let's think
about lenny's setup right where you know
you said you know you're given a quantum
state let's say you have n qubits and
you want to decide whether it is random
or pseudo-random like let's say whether
it's circuit complexity is exponential
in n or polynomial in n
or or you know whether one one of two
shock waves was applied to it you know
an a or a b shock wave we could we could
do these you know these different
versions okay um you know and then you
you answer that by jumping into the
black hole you know granted you know if
if if the state was maximally complex
then you'll just die at the event
horizon and you'll never learn the
answer but you know if it's not
maximally complex then in your last
seconds before you hit the singularity
you can you can know and uh uh um but
now you know what what i would like to
ask is how is the state actually given
to you because you know what what i
would like to know is you know if if
this does give us
power beyond what a quantum computer
would give us then how much more power
you know what exactly could we solve
could we solve np complete problems for
example okay but you know the the
what i found in thinking about this was
that the answer uh depends you know sort
of very much on on on on what we take
the input to be so you know there were
three possibilities basically that i see
as being on the table the first one is
that the quantum state is given to you
as a quantum state just you know
physically you you're handed the n
qubits this was also the scenario that
that bowling peppermint vasaram you know
right yeah and and in this case you know
like i'm i'm pretty convinced you know
at least given the assumptions and you
know and so forth that yes you can learn
certain properties of that quantum state
that you know might have taken an
exponentially large circuit you know to
to learn with a standard quantum
computer but you know
you you know if you had access to the
interior then you could measure those
things now this is not you know in
normally when we talk about the extended
church touring thesis like people didn't
even bother to phrase it in terms of
well what if the input is a quantum
state they just weren't thinking about
that right you know
they were thinking about problems where
the input and and the output are both
classical okay so already to have this
discussion we are generalizing what we
mean by the extended charge storing
thesis you know to talk about problems
with quantum mechanics but okay fine we
can do that um
but you know you could you know maybe
that that that feels a little bit less
threatening for you know uh from the
standpoint of np complete problems or
something okay now a second possibility
would be that the in the state is given
to you as a gigantic table of amplitudes
like let's say two to the n amplitudes
right
and um in in that case uh uh you know
i'm again convinced that you would be
solving something hard the trouble is
that to even create the input would then
take an astronomical amount of time
right either that or else we could scale
it down to where two to the n is is
small like it's polynomial but in in
that case n would be logarithmic right
and so so we would then be saying that
the black hole would have only
logarithmic size and only a logarithmic
size bob could fit into it you know so
so not no not us presumably right you
know you have to be very microscopic to
uh to jump in and learn the answer um
now a third possibility uh you know
maybe like the most attractive one in a
way would be that the
the quantum state uh in lenny's problem
would be described to you via a circuit
to prepare that state okay and and in
this case you know we we get around all
of those problems right but the trouble
is that now by just examining that
circuit it might be easy to figure out
you know just like what shock wave was
applied like whether it was the a or b
shock wave it might be just manifest if
you just examine the circuit and so in
order to get a hard problem by that
third route what you would need is a way
of obfuscating the quantum yeah you need
a way of hiding the information about
what shock waves were applied or in what
order and you know whether you can do
that kind of thing i would regard as an
open research problem in quantum
complexity theory and quantum
cryptography you know which you know
people could very much think about even
with no motivation from quantum gravity
okay but but but but that is what the
question would then be right you know i
think you know i have only one real
substantive disagreement with you know
uh you know one serious disagreement
with with what lenny said in his talk
and this is where he talks about well
you know bob is just made of qubits and
so you know we can just think about this
whole experiment as happening uh um you
know in in all you know in a quantum
computer we don't we can dispense with
the actual black hole
and just you know
a a think about a simulated black hole
right i mean to me you know to me like
if that were true then in a way it would
make it less interesting because you
know to say that okay there is some
basis you know in which you can view
your quantum system or there is some
dual description of the system in which
it is solving a hard problem is actually
a very weak claim right that is that is
true for
for essentially any system you know as
far as i can tell right and to me you
know what is interesting about black
holes what is special about black holes
is that we believe based on classical jr
based on quantum field theory that there
is
this interior that someone who jumped
into the black hole could actually
experience
you know they couldn't tell anyone else
but at least they would have that
experience in the case of the simulation
i i don't know you know and i'd say your
guess is as good as mine
i think quantum simulation
is
not all that different from the reality
that it's trying to simulate
no these are these are these are very
ancient philosophical problems yeah no
but i think more so than the classical
context
um
all right okay anyway that was all i had
to say yeah that's that's great actually
i you know thank thanks for that scott i
i'd actually missed uh lenny had missed
your uh
your you know this this um this thought
that uh
you you you were you could actually
maybe even think about a quantum
computer doing all this because uh you
know because then that would manifestly
make it uh
you know quantum computers are what we
define the quantum chart extended stream
pieces with wow and except that he's
imagining this exponentially hard change
of basis right right but having the
observer's experience right yes but that
that that that was my point then it's
just kind of a mental thing yeah
yeah
than a physical one right but but theo
to your point i i would say that um
you know that once we once we uh
formalized the quantum extended ensuring
thesis
there is really this choice you know is
it a classical input or quantum input
and i'd view that as a relatively small
issue you know it's it's uh it's a
completely acceptable thing to say well
it's a quantum input yeah but but i
would i would agree that uh
that if you were able to move it to
whether whether input is an obfuscated
circuit that would be
you know that would be sort of icing on
the cake yeah i mean i would just like
to know is nature still censoring np
complete problems even here okay yeah so
in this extreme scenario yeah so look
that is
i
made my best attempt to try to define a
complexity class
i do not make and i claim that it's not
empty
i have no idea at all if it contains
income np complete problems
so it's perfectly reasonable to suppose
that np complete problems are outside
that complexity class which i think you
would like to say
well i don't know i'd like to know you'd
probably like to say that i'd like to
know the true answer yeah
yeah yeah but i make no claim there i
simply say this class is not empty
great
when when you were discussing the bfv
problem and and measuring the bridge
you were discussing the volume you were
saying there were two possibilities
there's one is that the the quantum
extended jet steering thesis is wrong
and the other is that the dictionary is
exponentially complicated
and then it seemed like you were wanting
to say that that was literally i was
literally quoting yeah yeah that okay i
i'm fine with those two possibilities it
seems like you're you're wanting to say
that the issue is actually the quantum
judge during pieces conjecture cueing
extending church hearing thesis
being wrong
whereas i think i would want to say and
my impression from what scott's saying
is that he would also want to say
um
that what the the issue is the the
dictionary being exponentially complex
and maybe you can think about that in it
in a different way in terms of
a new complexity class
but fundamentally even in the problem of
of bob jumping in and he sees a shock in
some stage or another state
uh then from the pure quantum gravity
description this is just he's measuring
something simple he's moving across and
he's looking at something simple and
the quantum gravity description the
interesting thing is that that's solving
a tricky problem in the quantum
mechanics description but the trickiness
involves switching switching
descriptions yeah um
but incidentally
i i don't regard all of this as a threat
to the thesis i simply regard it as a
reason to want to review what the thesis
means in uh
that
that
anytime new physics happens you have to
think how
how does it affect this thesis
and my own view is that the correct
version of it which is not threatened
involves observers on the outside
so i you know i i am ex very very
confident in saying that the quantum
extended church touring thesis is false
if and only if you know an observer can
concretely do something to learn the
answer to you know problems that are
outside of bqp i'm confident about that
what i'm not confident about is who
counts as an observer
okay so
this really brings that to the force yes
yes but what i'm saying is if we want we
want to retain
the thesis i think it can be retained
it simply has to be um
fine-tuned and it has to be fine-tuned
in this way
i don't think we want to abandon it i
don't think we want to say
it was completely wrong i think we want
to understand in what sense it should be
defined
so that it makes sense
i i would i would say it comes closer to
calling it question it into question
than we have you know in the sense that
one has to work now to to to save it one
has to maybe not work as hard but but
but to say look uh i mean what your your
example of jumping into the
you know into the black hole to to
answer a question that you
should not have been able to answer
because it's exponentially hard
i mean that's that's something and so
well you know
ruling it out by saying well you can't
jump in well that's that's uh that does
take some doing right you now have to
say well it's a little more
you know
the thesis is slightly more
circumscribed than we had we would have
thought earlier
if the discussion is supposed to be up
about things we do in the real world
first of all i would have thought that
the gravitational version of the
extended church touring thesis would
just say that the existence of gravity
doesn't let us solve any problem that we
can't solve without gravity
that seems like an economical statement
now whether this story with black holes
contradicts it
it's the rules are not terribly clear to
me the entangled pair of black holes
which are assumed is extremely hard to
make
so if we're asking something which we
can do part of doing it was creating the
geometry which was the starting point
it's not clear to me how we're supposed
to do that it seems off scale and
complexity to build that um i don't
think it's that hard but um
you know people are trying to do this in
the laboratory now create
entangled computers in uh in
something like the thermal field double
state to do quantum teleportation or um
traversable wormhole protocols
think about what would be involved to
actually um challenge
uh see
i think i will i will make the assertion
that i think that in a laboratory-built
device like you just said it will not be
possible to violate the church during
hypothesis by simulating the jump in
um
how would you tell if you did or you
didn't
i'm saying that nobody will succeed in
solving an intractably complex problem
with the devices you've just described
i'm not making anything the trouble is
that if they do then they can't tell
anyone about it
yeah
i i i agree with you edward i don't
think anybody you won't be able to find
anything you'll interpret that way
um
no i i don't know that that's right i
think uh it will just take a long time
to tell
i think uh
using various versions of quantum
teleportation
and um traversable wormhole protocols
and so forth
it will be possible to tell what
happened inside the black hole it will
simply take a long time i didn't say it
won't be possible to answer a question
like that i just said that um
you're just simply describing an
algorithm you make from cubits so by
definition
you won't be doing anything you couldn't
i said what i said my assertion at the
beginning was that you can't do anything
you can't do without gravity yeah and
having a machine that doesn't use
gravity in an essential way so you're
not going to contradict what i said
no i'm not trying contradicting what you
said i'm agreeing with it
but
formulation of the gravitational church
touring hypothesis thesis
which was that gravity doesn't enable
you to do anything you can't do without
gravity
unless you're willing to jump into the
black hole well
then we had to discuss what was the
setup where you did the jumping and you
suggested a setup where gravity had not
played an essential role in creating it
namely the laboratory-based qubit system
so i would say that system has gravity
just as much as any uh
well
i think we would
we should i'm asserting i'm asserting
that that's okay as a tautology
therefore that system can't do anything
you can't do without gravity indeed
so so so just to just to understand
you you're sort of formulating uh the
principle which uh
as saying
um
we cannot you know
in the you know outside of the black
hole we wouldn't be able to solve any
problem faster than with gravity then
without or some you know not much faster
and yes
is that yeah okay
the weak interaction extended church
touring thesis says that the existence
of weakened directions don't let you
solve problems you can't solve otherwise
yeah i don't think we're disagreeing
edward i think we're completely agreeing
the correct formulation
should simply say
that you can't do anything using gravity
that you can't do without it
but you need to make that correct
there is a question i think that is a
real question say you're given some
simply describable classic problem say
an np hard problem but it doesn't have
to be but something that is not in bqp
uh can jumping into a black hole somehow
help me solve that problem and such that
i will know the classical answer that
decision problem one or zero for some
small amount of time and then i hit the
singularity and i die and the problem
remains unknown to the universe it seems
to me that the answer to that question
is almost certainly no like i i
it would be very very very surprising to
me if the answer to that question was
yes the jumping into the black hole that
you you see something that you couldn't
otherwise see okay so
you've now committed yourself you've now
committed yourself
to saying no to something which i claim
to have exhibited
can be done
this is for a decision problem like a
classical decision problem
that is not in bqp so the the problem is
phrased in terms of i'm told some some
classical question say
what are the prime factors if well
that's that's not a good one because i
can do it in bqp but there's something
harder some threesat thing or something
like that
maybe uh i claim that if that problem is
not in bqp then i also won't be able to
find out the answer to it even if i jump
into it
so
so
so jeffrey i mean if if my obfuscated
circuit proposal worked then would you
count that as an affirmative answer to
that question
see so i'm somehow
phrased
so i give you a circuit you know which
in some obfuscated form either prepares
a state you know of a black hole or the
the cft dual of such a state that had an
a shock wave applied or else it prepares
the state that has the b shock wave
applied right but you know again you
know not not not via some obvious path
and then examining that circuit maybe it
would take me exponential time to figure
out whether it was an a or b shock wave
if the obfuscation scheme was a good one
and yet by jumping into the black hole
in my last seconds i could see the
answer to that i mean would you
i would consider that a contradiction to
what i just said i'm not ruling out that
as possible because who knows but yeah i
think yeah yeah i think i i i feel like
that is that is the question that's upon
us now so i actually i wanted to ask um
um ed i mean i so you know i mean like i
was also not impressed by you know the
you know the idea of like a a
constructed you know or hypothetical
observer in a simulation seeing the
answer to this problem right but what
about the scenario with an actual
physical black hole i mean would you you
know if if if that observed informing
observer in their last seconds saw the
answer to this problem i mean first of
all would you say that is plausible and
would you even see that as a meaningful
question to ask whether they did or they
didn't
well i find it somewhat plausible and
possibly meaningful i'm sorry to hedge a
little bit with those qualifications but
the setup is extremely difficult to make
that's what i said oh yes absolutely
i mean i mean i mean i mean making an
ordinary quantum computer is is proving
hard enough you know i i i wouldn't ex
you know uh
i wouldn't expect this to be rolling off
the shelves anytime soon
yeah but i think
making the system to begin with is sort
of part of the overhead that we just
assume is there and then the question is
how much harder
is it
yeah
i was part of the overhead
it's very hard to know exactly what's
there in other words if you need
exponential if you need exponential
precision in knowing what's there
and given that exponential precision
it's easy to do something that seems a
little bit artificial if i go back to
the statement that gravity doesn't let
us do something we can't do without
gravity then we have to take into
account the difficulty of making the
apparatus that we're supposed to use to
do the computation
especially it's a single use apparatus
well whatever the difficulty is in
making the apparatus we can ask given
that difficulty and given that we did it
how hard is it
to accomplish the task we're trying to
accomplish
and there are two different answers one
comes from jumping into the black hole
the other comes from looking at um
at quantum
complexity well i think you should
compare quantum complexity to the
combined complexity of building the
entangled pair of black holes and then
jumping again
i mean there was a ton of objection to
quantum computing itself in the early
days you know along the lines of well
you know you won't be able to make the
apparatus right or it is a it is you
know it will require exponentially
precise control right and that was a
plausible view a priori and it was
ultimately i would say only really
answered by the theory of quantum error
correction right you know it's you know
by very non-trivial schemes of course it
will only really really be answered by
the actual building of the devices
that implement the theory but you know
this is watching learning it's much more
than a quantum computer he needs sources
whose functioning depends essentially on
gravity yes
he does not yes
yes so i think the question that one
could now you know start researching is
is there some analog of fault tolerance
for gravitational or black hole
computers you know where where you would
you would be able to uh
detect and correct the uh small errors
um
you know that that that would be the the
practical question so to speak
i think even if as
even if we accept that that we can do
these things with no errors
then to to focus on scott's like circuit
set up for the problem but let's we can
certainly make an obscure obfuscated
circuit that is exponentially long it's
some exponentially long way of we're
preparing some state
that actually has some some simply
observable thing but you can't tell what
that thing is because it's just some
some horribly obfuscated thing
um and then you could imagine from
lenny's point of view we ignore the
costs of carrying out the instructions
of doing that circuit that will take us
an exponentially long time
um but we assume we get to do that for
free and then we ask how much time does
it then take us to figure out the
problem and by jumping in we can find
the answer essentially immediately this
is a physical black hole uh if we're not
allowed to jump in then we're we're
still sort of at square one or it will
still take us a long time to do from the
outside
um
but
i think that's uh
yeah that's that's sort of a
very different problem from if you could
have some efficient obfuscated circuit
where there would really be
you know the
something that could efficiently be done
by jumping in a classical classical
problem the problem is completely
phrased in classical terms and it has an
answer in classical terms classical
decision problem um
that you could solve by jumping in and
you can
have that yeah i i understand what
you're saying i think i i don't know if
i agree with it or not but
you are asking now about the boundaries
of this um complexity class
you're asking whether it actually
includes any interesting computations
that could actually be done inside the
and i don't know
so so if i can say see you know there
are there are two things here it seems
to me one one is
um at this stage you know
surely we should be
we i mean we can think of all these as
thought experiments without saying
okay you know can we carry them out in
principle as opposed to how hard it
would be to
do it in practical terms but secondly
you know in terms of uh jeff in terms of
um
you know creating this obfuscated
circuit for for this for this state and
then then of course one one wants to
create it somehow homomorphically so
that so that now this state can be acted
on homomorphically by these
by the shock waves that are coming in so
so you fall in with this classical
description and then then you act on on
the on this uh hidden quantum state
and and you eventually end up end up
answering this question you know that
you that you really wanted to by by
saying okay now what's the volume of
something
yeah i i think my ejection can be
phrased as follows um
in
quantum field theory we think the
quantum extent just sharing thesis is
lenny made possible possible conditions
with that but let's let's assume that's
the case
then assuming everything we do in the
quantum gravity theory is well described
by quantum field theory in a
semi-classical background
um then it also shouldn't be able to
break the quantum churning thesis
so it seems we either need to be given
as part of the problem
a quantum state that has a non-trivial
um
non-trivial holographic jewel and so
some non-trivial trivial geometry that
we didn't make from scratch that's
that's the case in lenny's setup or we
need to somehow make that semi-classical
evolution break down
i would say from what we know about
quantum gravity to make the latter
happen we either need like planky and
curvature or we need exponential
complexity like exponential exponential
time exponential number of things
getting involved i don't think there's
any other i think i think it would be
very problematic for for semi-classical
space-time if if we could make it break
down without either of those conditions
being true um
so that's why i'm inclined to say that
it this shouldn't let us answer any uh
classical decision problems more
efficient
if i answer it now you are including the
possibility of jumping in and answering
it
yeah i will allow you to jump in but the
problem itself is just phrased as some
some short classical description of the
problem for example here's a quantum
circuit make and then you yeah does that
quantum circuit have you know
which of two states okay so how does the
a b problem not why is that not an
example i would say that's not an
example because you have to be given a
quantum state not just some classical
problem you have to be given some
quantum state and one that's a
holographic quantum state but you're
then allowed to to jump in is this the
distinction that scott was uh was
addressing
i think it's the distinction between
his first possibility and his third
possibility basically
i mean i mean but wait but jeffrey i
mean why not why not treat the
preparation of the holographic state as
just you know an engineering cost you
know and how it gets to building the
quantum computer you know yes
a billion times harder or whatever
so are you meaning building it on some
quantum computer or no no no i i i mean
i mean again like i i am viewing here to
the principle that you know you can't
draw blood from a stone or you know or
like uh change the computational model
just by thinking about something in a
different way
yeah yeah you need some actual physical
resource that will solve a problem you
know that beyond what a quantum computer
can solve and then the question is
simply you know are black holes such a
resource or not
uh
[Music]
my my claim and and i don't have much
evidence to this beyond i i don't think
you can make semi classical gravity
breakdown without either planking
curvature or exponential times
um is that
there shouldn't be anything you do to
make that like sorry
where did any of this involve
semi-classical gravity breaking down
i
like i just certainly didn't assume that
if semi-classical gravity doesn't break
down and i just start with some koshi
slice and i can just evolve that because
she slices to the future and the quantum
fields just evolve in some way that
seems to me that it's efficiently
simulable like with perturbed back
reaction on the geometry from from
having large amount of mass that that
just explicitly if qft is efficiently
simulable on a quantum computer then
then semiclassical gravity doesn't seem
any harder to just evolve the state
forward in time
in your case it would mean starting from
a kosher slice whether it's the shock on
the left and then you evolve forwards in
time and then that shock falls into the
black hole but yeah you you
at the early time you already have the
shock on the left and that kosher slice
so it's uh it's a simple thing from the
point of view of the quantum gravity
system it starts simple and it remains
simple so so what happened
that your semi-classical gravity
approximation
for such instances would not hold and is
there anything wrong with that
i think if you
if you
create two black holes by collapsing
them with some qubits
and then you you somehow managed to turn
that into a classical einstein raisin
bridge that would be an example of
something non-semi-classical happening
because semi-classically you just end up
with two black holes with a load of
entangled particles sitting inside them
um but to turn that state into an actual
thermo fuel double state that actually
has a classical wormhole short classical
wormhole seems seems hard to me um
yeah well well remaining inside the
system like uh
but but isn't it possible that you're
that that your semi-classical
approximation breaks down in other ways
than that i mean
that you haven't thought about so far i
mean you know we could start with a
computational problem
but i think i think lenny's suggestion
is a qualitatively different
it's it's the difference between
an observed what an observer just in the
quantum gravity theory can can do and
what problems they can solve with their
hand in a problem
versus what i can do if i'm handed a
holographic quantum system and then
allowed to jump into it versus not being
allowed to jump into it and i totally
agree
that the latter then there's things can
be simple if you can jump in but hard if
you can't jump in but i would have said
that's about the complexity of the
dictionary going between the two sides
yes
yeah
i i don't think i'm i think this is a
matter of wording like i don't think
that
i i really agree with with yeah the
basic story you're getting um yeah um
good
great
um let's see we we've run
pretty long it's it's been an incredibly
stimulating discussion i just wanted to
give
i don't know um
see if anybody on the panel had anything
else to say ed for example did you have
any final words
not really i think i'm satisfied with
the discussion
great
well thanks uh thanks again lenny for
for a fantastic talk and and uh thanks
to the panelists this was a really uh
you know very vigorous very interesting
discussion and uh
and really quite a way to uh to end our
colloquium series for this semester so
uh
thanks everybody for attending and see
you all in the in the fall
thank you
thank you bye-bye
yeah thank you thanks everyone
thanks lenny
thanks so much okay bye